The magic is in the follow-up.
Following up is everything in your business.
Too often, we talk to somebody for the first time...
...and we forget that it takes eight to 15 times of following up with somebody...
...to get them to say yes to you.
Isn't that crazy?
And so, I like to keep everybody on a drip list.
So, the first time I share with them my opportunity,...
...I want to talk to them within 24 hours to see how they felt about our conversation.
See if they're ready to make a decision.
And if they're not ready at that time,...
...I want to talk to them at least once a month after that...
...to continue to stay top of mind...
...when they're ready for a service or product that you have to offer.